hello friends I'm Ilana and welcome to
my channel with if I send a little bit
sick it's because I am kill me today I
am doing another Q&A for hitting 190,000
subscribers which holy crap
thank you guys so much I try not to
spend a long time in my Q&A is just
saying thank you but seriously just
thank you to all the new subscribers and
thank you to everyone who was stuck
around over the past I think five years
that I've been making videos it really
means a lot so today I already tried to
make this video once and then the power
in my apartment went out but the
conclusion that I came to was that there
are a lot of questions along the exact
same lines Dillon slack on Instagram
asked what did you gain from leaving IG
and personally and professionally and
what did you gain and joining funhaus
one comment down from ads Anderson 305
on Instagram oz what's the biggest
transition from working at IGN to
funhouse miscellaneous D on instagram
said can you compare working an IGN and
funhouse so I figured that I would have
all of those be the first question that
I answered because I got it a lot and
they are honestly extremely different
and working on very different projects
that have a different goal and every
system in making them is very different
I kind of don't know where to start
probably the biggest difference between
my day-to-day at fun house and at IGN is
that IGN I was a lot more isolated aside
from like having a lot of meetings
answering a lot of emails that was so
much of my job and sort of organizing
things you know months in advance my job
was very isolated in IGN I guess also
aside from doing the daily fix which is
very much a group effort but a lot of
what I was doing there was you know
producing a let's play which I would
then edit in a room by myself for
several hours and then I would organize
the schedule and I would get the talent
for the next one and stuff like that oh
I would write a review and that would be
mostly playing a game alone and then you
know writing the review alone and going
through the Edit oh I would do the
weekly op-ed videos opinion videos that
I was supposed to make which is they
were usually that the essay version
ended up being like a thousand words and
that's again me coming up with an idea
making it happen and doing a lot of that
alone in fact when I was working in IG
and I very often would go to a coffee
shop around the corner just so I could
get stuff done so I wasn't distracted by
everyone in the office and there are
some parts of like working along that I
totally love but
the biggest difference is that fun house
feels a lot more collaborative it feels
like a team working towards one common
goal and that probably comes with the
company being a lot smaller
I think IGN has several hundred people
and I think funny house is like 14 or
something so it really feels like we all
have the same goal everyone is helping
each other all the time and probably the
coolest thing about working their voice
is every other company I've ever worked
at is that I would like tell them an
idea that I have is something and their
response is like okay let's make it
every other company in the industry not
just IGN that I've ever worked at has
always been like okay let's have a
meeting make a pitch talk refine the
pitch talk we don't a budget right now
ba ba ba ba ba and they make it so hard
for you to make things not intentionally
that's just the way bigger companies
function when it comes to production and
I mean roosterteeth is huge but even
then it just seems like that company
culture is a lot more open to accepting
pitches and helping people kind of
curate their ideas how they want to do
them and just like trusting that you
will do it I also get to do other stuff
now I just announced this on my
Instagram yesterday but I've officially
recorded voice lines for a bunch of
video games that's a thing that I both
couldn't have and wouldn't have done
while working in IGN because they're
like ethical issues with working for an
outlet that reviews games and being in
those games but I got to do stuff like
that now I get to do um like I'm doing a
stream for GameSpot on Friday it's a
thing that I imagine IGN would have said
no to so it's like I just have a lot of
freedom to do more stuff and be more
myself it's very nice I hope that was
star enough let me know if you have any
more questions that are most specific
but I got a lot of questions along this
line so I thought I'd just get that out
of the way all right
Shang guy under school one 108 on
Instagram oz what was the last game you
played that you honestly couldn't stand
despite wanting to like it probably
night in the woods have a lot of friends
who love that game I know a lot of
people in the industry you love that
game it just wasn't for me I just
couldn't get into it I'm not down with
the teens and I I don't know I really
didn't find it relatable and didn't it
just felt so mundane and I know that's
the point I guess it just didn't appeal
to me Japan does will we soon see the
return of red lips orange car a lot of
people have been asking me about this
lately I was hoping to have it come
in September but because I ended up
starting work later at fun house than I
expected because of visa stuff I pushed
it but I'll work on it yeah hopefully
you liked this month or next month it'll
be back I'm just trying to figure out
how to bring it back I don't think I
want to bring it back to YouTube I think
maybe just on podcast services but I'm
not sure let me know because I really
don't want to have a video component I
want it to stay audio based might take
it off YouTube I don't know yet Ziza
underscore muniya said what's the most
scared you've ever been while playing a
game I love this question because it's
so easy for me to answer the most scared
I've ever been one playing a video game
and I love horror for the record my
favorite video game is a survival horror
I love horror movies but the most
chilling moment in a game for me ever is
in Silent Hill PT where the audio says
look behind you I just the first time I
heard that mmm mmm something about a
game telling me to look in a certain
direction whoo-hoo palms are sweaty
knees weak arms are heavy there's vomit
on the sweater already mom's spaghetti
he's nervous but on the surface he looks
calm and ready to drop bombs dear on 42
asked ever play runescape did I ever I
think I had my first boyfriend on
runescape Ajay sir na was here ask can
you record my voicemail love your accent
yeah you know mate I can't come to the
phone right now you can catch me on
instagram at AJ Cerner was here I'll
leave a message thanks mate when I do an
exaggerated accent I always sound more
like a dude people say I sound like a
dude anyway sometimes gets gets worse I
don't know what Ian jirafa
asks you reading any comic book series
if so which boy I got a show-and-tell
for you I mean I always read Batman is
my answer I'm always that's the only
thing I'm up-to-date with but I just
thought Batman damned I spent a lot of
money on this because it's sign inside
the cover but also because if you
haven't heard about it let me find the
page this is the comic the features
Batman's dick DC kind of found out about
it when it went public so they stopped
running it so it sold out extremely
quickly making this limited-edition I'm
gonna put Batman stick on screen right
now if you don't want to see that just
skip ahead oh you can barely even see it
anyway whose dicks like right there
also Batman damn was very good what god
damn light died again I don't even care
anymore Sidious let's go of Vindico
underscore hmm sorry said most boring
job you ever had and why son I worked in
a call center I did tech support awful
Ilya alex f ass you work full time DJ
stream make youtube videos make a
podcast right and probably a more I'm
missing how do you decide which project
you're going to work on is it
frustrating trying to split your time
between everything or is it refreshing
to work on a wide variety of projects no
doing the amount of stuff that I do
especially lately has been annoying the
[ __ ] out of me because I also paint and
draw and I read a lot and I go to the
gym every day and I swim and then I try
to have friends and I like to travel no
I've actually been getting really
annoyed and I've been getting to this
point where I'm like how do people pick
which of these things that going to do
because I don't know how to choose
between them how do if you have any tips
for how you pick what you do I've been
thinking about like maybe writing every
day and being like on Mondays I do this
on Tuesdays I do this or whatever it's
like it sucks
hey I'll just go 3.7 us what do you
think about Red Dead 2 so many people
here asking me if I am excited about or
will I be getting or playing Red Dead
Redemption 2 and I just want to be like
guys come on now obviously I will kid
snuggles us what are you currently
watching on Netflix Hulu or Amazon
nothing I don't watch TV
I don't watch shows just play video
games the company who does my cable cold
the other day I'm like hey we want to
offer you a deal for streaming what what
kind of shows do you like watching I was
like none of them you're like what do
you what do you what do you mean I was
like I don't watch any shows like what
do you what do you do with your spare
time I play video games
my mental mutiny on Instagram asks what
advice would you give for someone trying
to break into the gaming industry as a
personality as Rooster Teeth calls them
don't I think that if you are trying to
be a personality or a host or someone
who is on screen yet ultimately means
you don't have many skills I may produce
a I can video edit I'm mostly fluent in
writing
that means that I have those skills and
then I also worked at getting good on
camera not good I worked at being
tolerable on camera sometimes to some
people I think that if you are trying to
be a personality or just a host or
something like that you are setting
yourself up to fail and also kind of
screwing yourself in terms of like
career longevity that only goes so far
it's also from everyone I know who's
ever had a job like that seems to be
very boring wouldn't recommend it just
have other skills
Erick's aaron said what are your top
five games but to make it interesting
each has to be a different genre I like
this question bible hora is Deadly
Premonition action-adventure is Batman
Arkham Asylum RPG is fallout 3 oh that
one was tough not confident moving on
first-person shooter is halo 2 puzzle
platformer is banjo-kazooie banjo-tooie
and that is it for now thank you to
everyone who submitted questions I
answered most of them except for things
that I've answered a million times
before like my favorite game though I
also probably answered things that I've
answered before because I've been making
skewness for a long time now and I don't
I remember if I seem more low-energy
than my usual very chill self yeah it's
because I'm sick I'm sorry already
friends I will on it and I will see you
guys next time bye